This unit is about simplifying.
Why is simplifying important?
Think about a plane catching fire as it leaves the runway.
When you think about how could that possibly have occurred,
you want to figure out what the cost of failure is.
In order to explain how the failure came to be,
you want to come up with the minimum of factors that explain how.
So, here is our plane with passengers, luggage on board,
entertainment system, air condition, and whatnot.
Now suppose you had a means to turn back time and repeat history at will.
Or suppose all of this were running in a simulation.
You could try again and again to see whether the failure occurs or not.
Then you could try to simplify things.
You could, for instance, remove the passengers and see
whether the failure still occurs. Oh, it still occurs.
Remove the flight attendant and see whether the failure still occurs.
Well, the plane still catches fire.
Remove the seats. The plane still catches fire.
Remove the air conditioning system and repeat the whole thing.
And remove the entertainment system, remove the luggage,
and you see that none of this actually is important.
Whatever you remove, the plane still catches fire.
You can go and remove the airport, and even with all the airport removed,
everything happens as before.
But as soon as you remove this little metal strap that's lying on the runway,
then all of a sudden your plane takes off just as normal.
But if that strap is there, then your plane is on fire.
What we're going to explore today is how to simplify failures--
that is, finding what is relevant for the failure and what is not--
and how to do this automatically--
that is, automatically finding out the cause of the failure.